being a seven-year-old girl I having a
grown man look at your price and you in
between your legs
it's just that appalling I'm
uncomfortable it made me feel whenever I
wasn't even supposed to know what those
looks men I grew up in Kansas City
Missouri
and I grew up in foster homes I didn't
meet my father in I was seven and it was
just a short couple of years that I
visited with him um and there was an
alcoholic incident on my tenth birthday
and I didn't get to see my dad again so
I was 20 and I passed away when I was 23
I I met my mother when I was 15 in the
penitentiary for murder and I see with
the original foster family from six
months until I was 13 I was basically
their slave my foster brother sexually
molested me so I grew up in my original
foster home from six months at 13 years
my foster brother that was about ten
years older than me and molested me
sexually
I would black out and I knew the boogie
band was coming I could smell him and
later I learned it with dirty sprouted
up yeah I bet have to take off all my
clothes and cover up with just this she
and I would wake up in the morning it
would just be another day incredibly
people asked me I'm in the profession
that I'm in now I'm how'd I get so good
at what I do and it was because I was
molested since I was seven and I pretty
much you know do everything the same way
yeah I like to add my own SACEM
possesses but um I basically do
everything the same way that I was
taught when I was a child my father
parents used to physically emotionally
mentally and financially abused me and
so sometimes I was made to stand in the
corner for 10 hours because I was 5
minutes late coming back for my
girlfriend's house
one time we took a family photo and they
was meant to this year is stored and had
a portraits made of them and then they
come home and my foster dad would take
pictures of the whole family for the
Christmas pictures one time there was a
kid named Tony with us and I was uh I
was the one that took care of all the
children that came in the home I had to
watch them feed them and take care of
them and uh we were uh we were two got
neighbor's house and uh he kept taking
candy out of the candy dish
all right oh my father mom when they got
back I had a report she gave him a black
eye I was this big and sat him down in
front of the camera with the family
injured yeah he was crying might be
right after it happened
I learned from that day forward should
never be as in it
so uh anyway whenever it's 13 I kind of
became a Red Bull and 13 I took the car
and wrecked it
yeah all the kids were harassing me and
[ __ ] the neighborhood so part my friend
so I don't kept down here I'm gonna run
away and so they put me in a group home
and I had already tried marijuana and
was smoking cigarettes at the age of 10
I started and then at 13 of your I
started smoking cigarettes every day
marijuana every day I ended up going to
actually two other foster homes the next
one was with the woman that I believe
truly was a mother she had been a victim
of rape and had two twins by the rape by
our rapist and I raised him and she
raised me but she was with the gentleman
that I was starting to Rumi and I'm left
me and she caught him a French kid they
made
I was on my knees in between I was on my
knees in between his legs and she caught
it and moved us out and she had a house
and we moved into the house until she
met another man shortly after that and
she married him and I took her car for a
joyride
I gather and record in the pasture and
they serve me out and so I went to my
pastor song nobody else wanted me and so
I went to my pastors home until I
graduated high school and I was 19 when
I graduated high school and I was 15 out
of 25 people in my graduating class
during high school I would go out in the
morning click the chicken eggs from the
chickens
I would castrate the steers in the
cattle in the springtime brought up
they'll say hey for the cattle work in
the garden
mess with the horses and stuff you know
and so I graduated high school I got
married when we got high school and I
that marriage lasted about nine months
it he that he just quit working and our
relationship then I was the only one
that was making the burden in the in the
relationship and I left and he got a job
later to up divorce me so I line it was
to get a job and so you got a job to
divorce me so anyway I yeah I had a
little studio apartment I work two or
three jobs in order to maintain that um
had some to multiple choice stuff
abusive relationships and I ended up in
st. Louis Missouri
I'm and 2001 I was well I was 20 I was
getting out liquor on my out fake ID and
um so then I met my second husband and
that was my baby's daddy and we had the
baby but his company was transferring to
a more central area for them to ship
their product from and we decided we
would take the baby and go home with his
family in Pennsylvania I just we can
race my son with his family because I
didn't ever have any and really about
ailment I met the rest of my family they
were older than me and we just didn't
have a connection so and it was ironic
that my foster family had the same
number of boys and girls in sequence as
my room mother did so they had including
me they had five and it went boy girl
boy boy girl and my
had five children and they were pretty
much the same ages so it's kind of all
right you know that anyway I'm so uh we
decide we go to Pennsylvania and I'm
gonna try to raise the baby there he
couldn't get a job and fell into a deep
depression and I had spent a little bit
of money on some clothes because my
maternity clothes were hanging on me and
so because I was a bread winner at the
time I made the decision to buy some
clothes and when I got home I was beaten
and my jaw broken and I left and his
mother had a baby at the time so I I
went back and eat with him take the job
in Georgia Nana so we did and off we
went to a Georgia man I spent 11 years
in Atlanta Georgia and the relationship
with him and I had I just didn't trust
and after knee that that I just I
couldn't trust Anna
he had this idea of me being a
stay-at-home mother and because I had
always taken my care of myself
even from a young age 7 I couldn't
depend on a man and take care of me
and I kept my job and I wanted to be a
working mother and so I was abused and
ridiculed for that and I left my left
from my baby was - and I didn't take my
son because he taught me slit my throat
like Oh Jade and he looked at my eyes
and he said and I knew he was serious
and so I left I left with the baby with
him and continued my life
we had a pallet business that we're
bringing in $6,000 Castleman alone just
from pallet business and he told me I
didn't have to pay child support ask my
part of the business and so I left him
we had a bring it written up but
unfortunately it was said written up
incorrectly the judge when it went
through said this is backwards you need
you have it correctly written and
resubmit and I will approve and then of
course we couldn't find the guy he he
took our money he took off and so I had
paid for it and as part of our agreement
and so the paperwork didn't get I drawn
up a ticket back to court for a year and
a half and I'm during that time I had
two jobs to maintain the two-bedroom
apartment I had for my my son and I when
I got custody of him and then come to
find out my remain I got a roommate
during the time that the process was
going through it helped me pay for the
apartment we would buy groceries and
things together and so when Christmas
said I was paying for it and she put her
stuff in with mine and mine had my son's
diapers and toys for Christmas and all
that and she had personals in there
condoms shampoo bath soap and so when
the receipt was discovered by his lawyer
when we took it back for custody because
of the laws in Georgia if you can prove
that there's infidelity in the
relationship you're awarded you know you
win the case and they found the receipt
for the box of condoms took my childhood
as instability and I lost I lost custody
of my son
and it was devastating for me instead of
saving for me because I live my life
right
and that my life depends I could and I
love I said I did everything for my son
that I could during that time I wasn't
able to maintain you know like two
consecutive days together or two jobs I
had my days off right clay are we going
to my son but it wasn't a lot of
together quality time and they also felt
that that was unstable for my son so I
was basically picked apart in the
courtroom
I had lost custody of my son and he was
awarded $400 a month
child support which was 25% or both of
my incomes and so I had to go bankrupt
it ruined me financially
base all our lies you know and so a
deception in order to win you know
and so as most bullies do you know both
these do that kind of thing
so I quit my job and when a temporary
service and I was looking for our
administrative positions during the time
that Atma US healthcare was that merging
I was working as a temp for the office
manager of a u.s. Health us a US
healthcare and I was subject to sexual
harassment for my boss I had to I had to
uh orally take care of him in order to
keep my position but in the Indian
process that I met my fiancé at four and
a half years and he he was my life you
know I am
he took him best anyone probably is
everything care me my life but his wife
had passed away at 28 years in it
I figured you know in the beginning that
you know his shrink he won't be bad but
it would get better my but at the end of
our four and a half year relationship
we'd only had one domestic dispute it
did involve a gun however you know we
work things out in a relationship but we
went and discuss our problems in the
heating I have anger while we were
drinking I and it it worked out it was
it was nice and I he'd asked me several
times at the beginning of the
relationship if I would marry him and I
couldn't trust and through the trauma
I couldn't commit enjoying you and spend
some time and I asked him if I could I
worries rating for the four and a half
years and I asked him if I could ask him
to marry me when I felt right and so I
did and at the end of the Cornett years
he don't be no and so I decided to leave
there wasn't anything left we couldn't
move forward and so I left and I got
into a ecstasy
let's take an ecstasy and a cocaine at
that time that was so I first tried
ecstasy and I was drinking I was a
full-blown alcoholic at that point I was
taking ecstasy I went to a powder
cocaine and I've gone into some BDSM
websites and
just sex website so don't first mind her
and so I was said you know doing
threesomes I was a swinger I uh I have
enough time of my life I thought I
thought you know I experience a lot of
different things sexually kinky a lot of
kinky things I met my third husband
through those sites and the first time
that we were ever together was some
years of a 2000 and 2002 and I we had a
sex party
there was six couples there and
basically we all watched him do all the
women and I wanted to try a threesome
you know with two men and me and the guy
that was behind me he went soft him so I
never really got to experience that
better I thought in the back of my mind
that maybe I might have a problem with
this guy
he seemed to be to all put together but
very experimental sexually we build a
dungeon or house theater lakefront home
and Atlanta Georgia and I 500 feet of
lake foot property
I had a car my dreams
the car his dreams we had a Harley and I
thought I was on top of the world but I
thought I had a problem with him I
thought it might be a sexual predator or
just be I never maniac okay you know I I
did everything with him that he wanted
me to do sexually we had all kinds of
sex toys we had a dungeon or our own
house I would go and he went through a
dua and lost his license and so he was
continued to be on the sexual sites
because he wanted to find a slave for us
they drive him so he continued do hit
that construction work then take care of
his business throughout the day and I
was all for it and I bring girls home
from the city and drive back out to the
lake home for him to interview as [ __ ]
you know see how they felt with us and
see how they would fit and one
particular night I brought this woman
out Anna I had to go to work the next
day so I went to bed and I woke up to
him coming in frantically are trying to
get my get me to wake up and she said
she's calling 9-1-1 she says I threaten
her with my 9:00
which I knew what what it was you know
his dick and I mean that it was true
without even talking to the girl but I
had to protect my husband and so the
police got there and I'm she's drunk
sang on our steps and uh they're telling
us they're gonna shoot the dog if we
don't get the dog off off the police
because it was you know dishes and I
went to step down the steps the police
officers were to my left she was to my
right and I bumped her and she flew over
the rail of the steps and let her on her
head and went unconscious and I they
arrested me first on battery and that
was the first time that I had ever been
to two jailers I stayed in Milan
thinking and he got me out but you know
he got me out everything was cool in
Anna
I ain't never cheered on him I bet he
constantly accused me of cheating and I
figured it was the guilt because he was
doing the same thing to me and clothes
and stuff in the house and I had cleaned
all of his stuff daughter's clothes out
of the house and so uh I had a position
a very prestigious position now payroll
benefits administrator for a utility
it's a company in their corporate office
and I did all the benefits and payroll
420 Union
I was making I was bringing home over
$4,000 months in Atlanta and I bailed on
him at about 1200 so we had plenty of
money to do what we want to do what we
wanted to have and everything and then
he would harass me at work and try to
get me fired they try to get me fired
because of him and so I left the company
and we got a constructor and we started
his construction remodeling company back
up and I knew that he couldn't do what
he used to do whenever I was at work
once I was at home and the physical
abuse became more severe even choked me
I choked me out punch me push me maybe
in the upper torso tell me to shut up
and call me names in front of the
construction crew and so he to say that
we were going to take in a trip to
Florida and I thought it was gonna be
really cool
yeah I had to drive and I when I got
down there I had a migraine headache and
so we had put the two boys that were 12
and 13 in their own cabin and we had our
own Kevin and I said I was gonna go take
him now and when I woke up he was gone
and the boys were in their cabin and he
was gone for hours and hours and hours
and I even went to look for him
and you then you probably went down and
met somebody and you know it's off you
know
texaco sexcapade but I was just tired I
was tired of it
I want to know what I wasn't doing
sexually for him because I gave him
everything he wanted to ask or sexually
with enthusiasm you know above and
beyond
you just have please you can't leave
that type of person ever they just want
more and more anymore you can give
everything you have a beer self and
never get the accepted there left that
you're looking for and so when he got
back I had up I had cut the rope to the
latch on the door and locked the a
window so he can get in the cabin and I
said it sings outside he broke the
window to get game it took my phone's
like it got Eggman one punch me threw me
against the loggerhead board at the bed
which broke my back and dragged me to
the middle of the bed that on me full
weight at six foot five 210 pound man
sat on my chest a strangled man's by the
foods I passed out for dead at words
when I woke up I had I had a huge bruise
on my chin of my face his handprint
I mean facing on my chin and I knew I
was in trouble and this one we got Becca
I decided right then and there that I
was gonna leave him and we got back up I
went to the bank to take out my portion
of the many Anna he had taken thirty
thousand dollars out of the bank account
and left me with nothing and I had
secretly paid off some credit cards and
I drove myself back to out Missouri from
it the Georgia by myself and I took all
the construction equipment commercial
construction equipment that we had
because he took everything else out of
the house it was a value and at time it
to Missouri I became a methamphetamine
uh interviews drug user for a four and a
half years and I did anything and
everything to maintain that addiction I
sold I shoplifted I robbed people
I am I had a sugar daddy I ended up
stabbing him because he abused me
I started getting five times I punctured
his glove
kind of quest here I cut him across his
chest
and I I hit him twice in the lungs on
the side and I have this scar here right
accidentally cut myself I didn't feel it
was cut when they sewed it without pain
relievers what it was healing or
anything and I knew I had a problem so I
he lied for me I ain't go to jail yes I
came to the hospital and ask me
questions and I passed and got out of it
he was wonderful for that I've stabbed
in my life yeah most of it was just
protection because they were up they
were mean to me and I didn't know why
they didn't have any reason to treat me
that way and so up because that my
mother my father are were both murderers
I've always been very scared of myself
and my temper and I've always tried to
be very mild-mannered however now that I
get older I am
I don't have a lot of feeling I cried
for I cried for myself and I also cry
for what I could do what I know I have
in me and it hurts and sad I I left
Missouri ahead of sum of money up and I
left my job I was in recovery 2010 I got
sober from them 13 year-old colic and
four and a half year right everything is
crystal meth user and my recovery is
short-lived
I don't step back and forth with crack
cocaine methamphetamine and drinking and
so uh
I never really from the apartment that I
had into Georgia I never got that one I
know their apartment of my own until
2009 well I guess or Noah yeah - yeah
2012 I had it for one year and I go from
one minute come out to at California and
you know Judea Jolla Sunshine Beach
thing every day was going to be a party
and that's what I've made it since I've
been here
there was some recovery and there ain't
tried to but I maintain my recovery I
have a schizophrenia
I'm schizoaffective bipolar type I call
my personalities Monica Victoria and a
baby girl and it started out as a joke
cut but it's real and I'm so uh I came
out here to California the second thing
I was out here I had it gotten put to my
head
Anna my best friend boyfriend said that
I was disrespecting her and I just kept
bouncing my forehead officer I'm not
asking him to shoot me I having out of
my knees and looked at him straight in
the eye I wanted him to shoot me
I haven't every one of the lips if that
was seven but everything started being a
seven-year-old girl I haven't a grown
man look at your breasts and you in
between your legs
it's just that appalling I hun
comfortable it made me feel whenever I
wasn't even supposed to know what those
looks meant and so uh
right-left job I was living with my best
friend
she gave me about two seconds to get out
of her house when she thought the money
was gone and she took all my clothes I
had spent two and a half days in the hot
Sun in New Mexico Albuquerque New Mexico
trying to go to my clothes to uh figure
out what I was gonna bring and I had
about six to seven thousand dollars
worth of clothes in my ass Honda Civic
and I made it all the way to Albuquerque
New Mexico for my car broke down and so
uh anyway else those were all gone you
know within a month so me being here and
I you know I thought I could uh you know
bring out my nice clothes and uh you
know I could find a good sugar daddy I'm
being the UM you know the high class
district cinnamon you know maybe be okay
you know I wasn't you recovery went into
a better woman shelter in Compton and
was a transitional living home anima I
just about drove myself crazy and with
the insane it drove me insane
I'd be in the shelter or with the other
women because it's got the same goes up
anyway it's been abused makes a great
abuser and so I left there and I went to
eight another mental health program and
during that time I created a
housekeeping business I'm and I was you
know well for what I thought four or
five hundred dollars you know every so
often and that carried me through but
then I started smoking crack every day
when I found my mother died
oh the only one that cared about me I in
in and she would send me a birthday
cards with a little bit of money in it
Anna just I let your card here and there
and it meant so much to me from somebody
made in my life never reached out like
that to me and so I I took it really
hard because I knew this the end of
anybody to ever would care about me like
that again of my life and so uh I've
been out doing drugs every day since and
it brought me down here I didn't have
any money to live and my addiction winds
up more important than maintaining any
type of a house yeah haven't helped
didn't have any value I uh you know I'm
a camping every day you know since I've
been down here well for two-and-a-half
years I did and I love camping roars
KITT you know I like that I just like I
was just a big amateur you know chemi
and then you know I uh I had
one of the drug dealers down here asked
me you know if I want to try to start it
and then look out for me you know and
they gave me all the basics that I'm you
know who do it
I started up I started the sex Walker
position I guess are a profession that
March 6 2017 the first time I ever did
it I'm 49
um so uh it's been uh it's been good to
me
I had my my renan's not necessarily with
my uh my clients or friends the white
callin I by the way the locals I've been
learning to attend and I'm giving crack
with that GHB lace on it there you know
about and commit to two and a half hours
later with my pants unbuttoned my shirt
off filthy no bra and my hair mess and
uh there's a piece of crack tossed to me
and I asked the guy
if I take this do I have to do anything
with you and I walked out at the tip and
I went up to the guy that lured me in
there and I stepped it I step
and I walk away
I don't go in tents anymore unless it's
my help because every time I've ever
gone into another tenant it happen good
um I hear you know suit ends around yeah
I need to stay away from them because
they will drag you in muzzle you and
they will do it they want to do with you
before I got put in my temporary housing
uh every night for three weeks on the
street that I they've done there was a
woman screaming for help some time it
was fate
I think last breast that they were
taking for a help other ones we're up
more energetic gomorrah
more loud and more frantic i I figured
those someone had just gotten dragged in
it it's trying to get away as quickly as
they could but that's another Mike isn't
it that I couldn't say anything all
right
it would happen to me I believe 95% it a
my heart and soul and I had been told by
six different people that I would be
unconscious and they would walk into my
tent and find men funneling Miya Miya
breast empathy and ass and sometimes I
would be responsive but not myself you
know the tongue I wouldn't I believe
that was to get a little bit of crack
money I figure probably my [ __ ] was
sold for five my ass for 10 maybe so the
person that would want to have it high
with his girlfriend and
even as we speak of it I have people
harass me people try to play tricks on
me or get me caught up there trying to
sneak into my apartment I finally got an
SRO which has been six years in the
making I found out and it was that
reconfirmed in a June that I have a safe
street just say four kids a full five I
hug phobar cancer and how you get that
at the to the HPV virus I have been
vaccinated against that Anna I am not
contagious
however I'm sure that it's moved to
States for it's going to mail it notes
and a lot of people say you look great
but I've lost a lot of weight and the
weight that I began it quickly falls
back off I'm constantly I'm gonna sleep
and eat to try to gain weight that I
have um people ask me my pregnant
because my stomach it in see yeah the
cancer right
yeah all they ever wonder whether the
love acceptance in a piece in my life
and I'm breathing I've never been given
that really an up brief and senses
throughout my life I had that I've been
a survivor from 49 years I've tried to
commit suicide twice because I've been
down here oh yeah I split this in my
artery I was exposed on this day and I
don't know why I cut this with a
straight razor and I did this one there
but I was too quick I just barely opened
the skin here and I turn off running I
with my I'm stop thinking that way up
make the blood flow faster it's like a
die faster and as anything with that
like it only made it quite late and I'm
Wrangler with that open gashes arms with
dried blood thank achievement I was
waiting to try to increase my heart rate
to let the blood flow faster
and then it only made it quite late
faster and ran around with a you know
gaseous and so I'm you know i I've tried
doing things as that's what I could the
person minute has said that they love me
for two and a half years has done
everything that I could think of to
destroy me as a person try to take my
heart and my soul and I gave it my heart
for a little while and then took it back
uh he's throwing that huge ham the
enchilada sauce at me full and beep off
my head hit me with a twelve foot board
like my I beat my head and torso
I have a bucks all over my head here
here here
all right back in here behind this year
and I have a plastic prosthesis and this
year is so I came here and there's a
huge about me here or I could severely
beat you I am I'm somebody I said they
love me so our last year or this year we
were fighting enough I was in our tent
and I tried four different ways of
trying to kill myself and even though I
have chickens running it up shot air I
found the impulse and I saw air into my
artery and then then do anything
I took a tourniquet and tied those times
I could rub my back and it broke
I put a bag over my head and tied it
with duct tape
it wasn't tight enough around my neck to
keep the area and so he told me your
take on my medication you swiped it
Bradley approve every single 90 pills he
called ambulance when they came I was
still conscious and told him I didn't
why didn't he help they let me go away
back down to the tip and left but I keep
my conscious he called him again
and they didn't want to take me he
begged him he begged mistake I died in
the emergency room I stopped reading and
why I asked myself why did he save me
why he a week
[Music]
I don't know I thank God every day that
I have the cancer I know I think because
I don't have to uh committed sin to be
able to have some mercy on my soul I
think God every day or what he's giving
me or not having to put me through hell
that day or any other people put me
through hell that day I asked me forgive
me of my sins
those noted I know and I ask you please
forgive me for fornicating commit oral
sex
I've asked if you don't send their souls
back to them and my ectopy and that's
how you by day
a hip fall asleep
I am I smoke cooking - a lot is - of to
kill the pain I saw him a broken back
and that cancer is spreading rapidly and
I just in pain all the time and I think
would hit to take the edge off
- heads is - up completely kill the pain
and the third one I finally get high
yeah there they don't even leave me
alone in my apartment the locals here
there they're breaking in my apartment
and wouldn't even give me any peace
they wouldn't even give me a sense of
security and what's supposed to be a
place of respite for me
and I asked by everyday dishes please
dig expect later so myself will finally
be at beads I don't even know if I'm
gonna be here a week from now